alors voilà ce qui est bien justement
ces textes extraits je crois est assez
significatif de films parce qu'en 45
secondes ils durent exactement quarante
cinq secondes mais au moins si gags et
le film c'est un petit peu tout ça y'a
pas de temps mort
alors je sais pas comment ça s'est passé
vous avez fait très attention au rythme
du staff et je crois que le montage est
excellent jeu jean marie a fait vraiment
un travail très très bon sur le montage
en plus dans l'extrait la serbie là
parce qu'on voit les deux personnages
que je christian jacquouille et son
descendant jacquard galante repris notre
château et ça c'est que les gueux sont
venues des seigneurs ça qui a changé et
est intéressant alors il ya plein de
choses intéressantes mais en
l'occurrence sur le plan technique il ya
aussi quelque chose c'est que clavier
ils jouent les deux rôles et les
enlèvements de touristes bas avec lui
même et s'embrassent lui-même enfin je
ne sais pas juste une image coupée en
deux avec les deux personnages
il ya vraiment ça tout va techniquement
c'est très dur je crois alors pour vous
expliquer maintenant vous développer il
faut je les foule qu'on peut jouer et
tourner les scènes deux fois l'espace
séparant l'écran et en remettant le
personnage deux fois cette nouvelle
devrait le pareils et christian aussi là
et de personnages mais ça résume
beaucoup le film dans le sens que c'est
un film d'aventurés comique est aussi
fantastique parce qu'il ya pas mal
d'effets spéciaux fait pas des pompes
par des français et ça il faut vraiment
dire si je dis que c'est un peu les
monty python à la française le début le
début mais le film ne se passe pas tout
le temps moyenâgeux c'est pour ça qu'il
est difficile de parler de ce film il
est hilarant et il part dans tous les
sens voilà on peut parler de vous
peut-être ce cas par exemple valérie
d'aleris est vrai que alors premièrement
vous êtes pratiquement toujours absente
à la télé on voit jamais vos sketches ça
c'est volontaire au cinéma vous êtes oui
vous pensez non je pense que c'est pas
la peine d'aller montrer la moitié du
spectacle à la télévision je pense que
un spectacle un intérêt quand on s'y met
donc et d'ailleurs les spectateurs sont
venus alors tant mieux bon ensuite on
vous voit très rarement au cinéma pour
l'instant et là j'ai l'impression
franchement que ça va être le démarrage
pour le cinéma ça va démarrer très fort
pour vous écoutez je ne sais pas si
c'est mon quatrième film et c'est vrai
que c'est la première fois que j'ai un
rôle aussi important dans un film et je
suis très contente du film que j'ai vu
deux fois moi je peux vous dire c'est
irrésistible dans le film
jean reno est tout à fait vous vous êtes
très très bon side alors vous savez
faire sage très différent parce que vous
jouez un personnage vous êtes le
chevalier d'un bout à l'autre se dire
vous êtes en costume tout le temps tout
à fait c'était dur le costume oui oui je
faisait très froid à carcassonne c'était
pendant les inondations de cet été fait
et très chaud à paris puisque ont été en
août et en septembre
mais bon il faut le faire et là il ya
quelque chose de très drôle aussi cap du
est assez difficile j'imagine c'est le
langage parce que vous parlez un espèce
de vieux français qui est un faux vieux
français évidemment
mélangez 2 d'expression moderne tout à
fait on a essayé de traduire le vieux
français de façon à ce qu'ils soient
compréhensibles aujourd'hui on a fait
une petite recherche là dessus et je
crois que ça marche très bien mais ce
n'est pas tout le temps bien sûr c'est
non non je vous ai vu à l'époque rihanna
jeu mais c'est ce qui donne un certain
nombre d'effets comiques tout à fait en
scop c'est très crédible cette histoire
et valérie alors un petit peu vos
projets maintenant parce que justement
c'est le cinéma c'est le assène flamme
j'aime j'aime alterner les deux voiliers
j'aime le cinéma et le théâtre
oui mais la renardière pendant ce temps
là bas est là on a redit hier elle est
sous mon coude je la gardais côté
italien
mes cousins vont très bien j'imaginais
là tout le monde va bien
ouais mais je garde mon spectacle
beaucoup de peut-être que je leur joue
vrai peut-être que j'en écrirai un autre
j'ai aussi l'intention d'écrire un film
donc après cette sortie de fil je vais
travailler chez moi comme ça ça se voit
déjà en flash mais j'ai un projet avec
michel serrault qui est en train de se
développer et puis d'autres projets aux
états unis et je suis en lecture d'une
pièce de théâtre pour la femme m'a dit
bon ça va pas trop mal tout va bien
grâce à dieu
moi je crois que ça va très bien marché
les visiteurs mais on croise les doigts
merci jean regnaud merci merci valérie
lemercier
ok oui et bonjour à vos cousins à la
renardière voilà ce sillon